So, we need a directory
that will fit on chip.
Otherwise, to maintain coherence
between our caches that are very,
very fast, we will need to
look up a directory in very,
very slow memory which kind of defeats
the purpose of having these caches.
Some of the questions about this
directory are easy to answer.
For example, where is the home node
where we go to find the directory
information about the block?
And the answer to that is the same tile
that has the last level cache slice
where that block would be.
Because, if the directory entry for that
block indicates that none of the private
caches have it, then we want to look up
the last level cache to find that block,
so we might as well do that in
the same node that has the directory,
otherwise there would be a lot of
traffic between where the directory for
a block is and where the last
level cache for the block is.
So naturally they should
be on the same node.
But that doesn't really answer the
question of having a directory entry for
every memory block.
We have seen that we only keep the data
in the last level cache slice for
those blocks that we actually
have in our level 3 cache.
But a directory without any
changes would need to be for
every possible memory block that
might ever come into that slice,
which is a big problem because
there are a lot of memory blocks.
So instead of keeping a directory
entry for every memory block,
we need to realize that the entries
that are not in our last level cache,
or in any caches on chip,
really are not shared by anybody,
so we don't really have to
maintain that information.
So we will maintain what is
called a partial directory.
We don't maintain a directory entry for
every memory block.
Instead, our directory will have
a limited number of entries, and
then we allocate an entry in
this limited directory only for
such blocks that have at
least 1 presence bit at 1.
Basically, only for blocks that might be
in at least one of the private caches.
So for a block for which we know
that it is not in any L1 or
L2 cache, it's present only in the LLC,
or only memory for
that matter,
we don't need the directory entry.
Implicitly we know that such a directory
entry would just be all zeros, but
let's say that we have decided on
some limited number of entries.
We start allocating those entries when
we put flaws in L1 and L2 caches, and
eventually we will run
out of directory entries.
What do we do now?